[Music]
huh mean title my mother-in-law's car
right she's already mad because I'm not
a dentist you've been a cop for like 15
years or more
not only as being mad you're not a
dentist being stupid and not worth your
anxiety it's also a 15 year old issue
also John goes with this mother-in-law
bowls before just showing his I'm also a
cop badge also movie makes it seem like
this guy is bad because he's giving
McLean a ticket for parking here but
John McLean and his thinks he can park
anywhere he goddamn pleased his ass boys
and girls this is called a pager and for
about 15 years they were in vital
communication tools if you wanted to
score wheat the studio said yes we must
keep all the elements of the original
diehard in the sequel right down to
making it Christmas again regular Joe's
in Indiana won't be able to tell this is
die hard without the Christmas Thank You
Fred
Lynyrd Adkins is in a warmer clime with
a story that grows hotter by the minute
a warmer clime this reporter's posture
and speaking cadence over written
overacted that's the movie news
difference your movies primary villain
is clearly not to be trifled with
because he does his exercise naked also
that nudity is a choice right I mean
there's nothing inherent in the
stretches and poses he's doing where
nudity would actually make it better for
his body right I'm trying to figure out
if the movie just went with the nudity
for their show the bad guy is creepy
evidence or pre famed William Sadler had
a must have nudity clause in his
contract really this is probably the
most new to the infused expositional
seen in all movie history and although
this news is extremely helpful in
showing us that Esperanza and Stuart had
dealings with each other in the past
their next news story how to light up
airport runways with fire when the power
goes out could be helpful later you
never know seriously guys don't what the
man who has the fastest
remote-controlled drawing the entire
world this guy means business y'all
Stewart in Ascension Time their hotel
room exits to coincide with other bad
guys walking in the same direction so
that it would look cooler and look more
menacing let's be honest if you assholes
coordinated your watches that you should
have then you'd have all come out of
your rooms at once and not in this
cinematically staggered manner like how
these assholes are all in matching
military style jackets marching in
unison like soldiers and each carrying
similarly suspicious Christmas presents
yet to them they planned the perfect
cover and it works
American Airlines of course this movie
would find a way to put Holly on a plane
so she can be a damsel in distress again
and give John proper motivation to die
hard isn't technology wonderful
I fasted exclusively this woman brings
up technology merely as an excuse to
pull out her taser on an airplane which
yes will figure into the plot later and
even in 1990 I can't believe she was
allowed to have tried to done my little
dog because I'm an asshole you granny I
mean what the claim just happens to bump
into the main bad guy early in the movie
because this action movie is the
equivalent of your cousin's sloppy
attempt at poetry and Dulles is a huge
airport the odds these two would bump
into each other are like lottery winning
levels well it really something intimate
let's just pause for a second cuz just
after this McLean Stewart interaction
inside the airport we're going to cut to
Stuart's Midway outside the airport
taking over the nearby church they will
use as their base for the entire movie
my question is why the kiss Carl's
Stewart in the airport at all I love how
this tiny ass Church near the airport
has a full-time night watchman and that
he's got all the snacks and drinks
possible within an arm's reach when you
post general Ramon Esperanza has just
survived under heavy guard there's no
way the story would be this big of a
deal and on the news constantly or check
your equipment that I promised the Conor
wood line in your backyard movies will
have you believe that people just accept
any workers into a place even if they
haven't called them or know of a problem
this is buckwheat clubhouse is open
terrorists using little rascals names as
call signs apparently Dulles not only
has a huge Bank of modern-day phones in
one area but they also have old-timey
phone booths still set up in another
part of the airport for people who'd
like to report on Al Capone's
bootlegging trial also these assholes
who perfectly coordinated a hotel
checkout March somehow still need an in
Airport phone call to ensure all is well
with their plant thankfully for this
movie an intuition in general Jon sees
dude remove his secret earpiece and sees
other dude kick a mysterious package
closer to the first two I mean it's
McClane the most observant mother ever
or what also okay so this movie which is
telling me all the bad guys we're in the
same hotel earlier still has one bad guy
suspiciously pass a package to another
at the airport for some reason probably
so McClane could see it which was kind
of them John sees this asshole and later
follows him into the baggage room and if
not for this huge leap in logic by John
after a hugely convenient I think that
guy is suspicious moment the rest of
this movie couldn't happen
got a key for this door yeah why cuz I
want you to open it up McLean thinks
that just by asking for a key people
should just hand that over he looks
annoyed II even has to pull out his
badge for this the bad guys can somehow
hijack an entire Airport from a remote
location but needed to put some sort of
signal in the luggage area in order to
tap into the control tower
communications you know because this
movie needed a quick action
scene and a few crumbs of evidence for
McLain to follow McLain regular cop will
now defeat this special forces ninja guy
tag team yeah you attacked two bad guys
at once the probability is that the two
bad guys will fight you at the same time
your action will be one-liner is dumber
than usual
convenient abandoned cart of luggage is
abandoned convenient abandoned male
bikes are male bikes Cherie tackle the
bad guy but how many of these bags
ultimately got lost
I'm guessing half of them shove me back
you're as cattle car somehow Thornburg
is just now being told to leave first
class even though this plane supposedly
lands in 30 minutes or so also the odds
that this news guy from the first movie
and MacLaine's wife both of whom were LA
natives last we saw them would be on the
exact same plane approaching DC is
something bull also this is the first
time they've noticed each other even
though they were probably in the same
waiting area to get on the plane and
likely past each other during the
boarding of the plane I'm not allowed
within 50 feet of them 50 yards so by
keeping me in this section you are
violating the court order actually
asshole it would be in violation
anywhere on this plane honestly though
it's more of a violation of our
suspension of disbelief than a
restraining order is a crime scene SC
lacerio for Christ's sake that's up to
the captain the only reason this movie
is possible is because the cops at
Dulles are the worst cops in human
history you fail me again and the
chamber won't be empty seriously can
someone explain the bad guy kills his
henchmen because they failed him even if
something completely unexpected came up
movie trope is it to show that the guy
is so determined and evil that he's
determined to be evil yeah yeah I know
who you are you're the asshole that just
broke seven FAA and five District of
Columbia regulations but amazingly
McClean actually had to tell one of your
cops to bring him here despite breaking
all those rules also overly biased
against John Airport cop boss is overly
biased against John I got a reindeer
flying in here from the competin sue but
John McClane he's got a little problem
so your reindeer from the petting zoo
Trump's the dead guy in the luggage area
yeah yeah I know all about you and at
Nakatomi thing in LA it might make me
want to believe you when something like
this goes down but I'd much rather be
the black hole that nearly drags this
movie into unwatchable 'ti what sets off
the metal detectors first to letting
your ass are your brains but letting his
ass of course I need to borrow
this in this right back which just
happened to be within reaching distance
and also I'm an asshole
after getting bitched out by the airport
police chief and then running to an
airline terminal McClane still has
enough time to catch up to the dudes
wheeling away the body of the guy he
shot in the baggage room if he finds a
way to get out Powell back into the
action complete with a comical pile of
Twinkies you're not pissing in
somebody's pool are you yeah fresh out
of chlorine so many questions if you're
pissing in somebody's pool would you
even bother with the chlorine and would
it help and the book said close in about
an hour go get a drink
Airport clerk is instantly smitten with
John McClane because he stole her ink
pad and paper earlier and somehow she
didn't see the wedding ring that John so
proudly displays after this or did she
just a fax pen
hardy-har hilarious pond is hilarious
McClane finds his way into the control
tower because yeah guess I should just
accept this at this point
he'll a mr. trudeau roaming yeah that's
what I said about my last cholesterol
test
who wrote this looking looking Oh same
guy who wrote the first die hard and
some other guy I'm gonna blame the other
guy whose credits include bad boys Money
Train and the movie The Force Gene
Hackman into retirement welcome to
Mooseport for all the kinds of cilia
that's in this movie looks cool for a
movie but what the see blowtorching on
this electrical board
I mean burning wires might make break
but it won't make any work this is the
resume of a professional mercenary you
got the world's biggest drug dealer on
his way here now what do you need a
slide rule to figure this out
my brain is still stuck on that letting
your answer in your brains line this
using a slide rule to figure out an
airport mystery literally physically
hurt my brain hey now you're the one
that gave a septem body remember that
Dennis Franz NYPD blue audition tape
ladies and gentlemen after that those
planes low on fuel are gonna be circles
they're gonna be dropping on the white
house along great line but Dulles is
more than an hour outside of the DC
metro area so those planes will be
dropping on Virginia and not much else
foreign military one now I'm sure you
gentlemen are well aware of the unique
nature speranza like if it wasn't clear
before the circumstances for the plot of
this movie are incredible a high-profile
drug lord is getting sent to the US and
it's all over the news but dauntless
didn't beef up their security at all in
fact it's absolutely stunning there
isn't a military presence around the
airport with this kind of prisoner
landing also the u.s. decided you know
what let's send this guy on Christmas
one of the busiest travel days of the
year and send him to Dulles and not some
private airstrip where we can take care
of it
Jesus hey guys want to go to Dulles and
tour the control
power just let you walk in and wander
around apparently seriously don't try
this on your next trip to Washington
also why does this reporter think she's
gonna get anything from these people by
doing the job this way no guts no glory
sure but you've actually thought this
was a good idea Lobby security man the
film shows two guys here working lobby
security but given this movie's track
record day she'd either be dead or
passed out drunk considering their level
of aptitude so far
come on McClane just a few words okay a
few words golf thanks but I already got
that from Colonel Stewart actually he
said and you but this franchise has
never been good about remembering stuff
like that another basement another
elevator the same to have the same guy
twice studio note that someone passed
around when the idea of die hard too
came up accidentally got into the
screenplay also did you say another
basement the PME might at you spent zero
time last movie in a basement elevator
sure but basement you also how did he
make it to the basement by crawling
through the ceiling of an elevator that
went to the top of a control tower
I guess the movie just wants John to be
in whatever place he needs to be
whenever it calls for it and just
forgets how it's possible thank God for
this homeless asshole living and working
beneath the airport who has access to
blueprints and everything John needs we
are experiencing some technical problems
here
even if Trudeau isn't allowed to tell
the pilots to divert I am shocked there
isn't a secret code or special message
they can send to tell the pilots to fly
away all the flights move to delayed and
yet this mass of people somehow doesn't
write again John finds human-sized
ventilation shafts where you can travel
secretly in Christmas but none of the
SWAT guys or the radio guys stop to
wonder why there are a few workers here
painting the annex
quite honestly guys the shootout is so
poorly constructed I'm not sure who the
bad guys are none of these guys are
characters I did see Robert Patrick a
minute ago and I know he's a bad guy
because it's a movie but in 1990 not
even Robert Patrick knew who that was
also if this was supposed to be a SWAT
team they're the worst SWAT team ever
but that's pretty par for the course in
this movie for some reason the t1000
doesn't shoot this guy immediately Jesus
how high I jump what's that and how the
fuck is McClane uninjured by it one of
the help-wanted ads for this movie read
one plastic dummy with many years of
scaffolding collapsing experience
looking real optional this guy just
loaded this gun but of course it jams
when he has a chance to kill McClane and
instead of just picking up some dead
dudes gun he decides I'll just kick his
ass wait why didn't the bad guys just do
this in the first place you mean to tell
me that the whole reason they didn't
blow it up right away was so they could
bait a SWAT team to come here just so
they could kill them to what end
if this SWAT team is killed surely
another one would be on its way right
Lorenzo sacrifice his best man thank you
waste your time and we don't have well
there's the explanation but considering
you guys are operating from a secret
location with a number of ex-military
guys at your disposal it's a total waste
and plus they actually gave credit to
this dumb airport that someone would
actually think of the new antenna array
and that Lorenzo would send a SWAT team
there the recalibrates sea level
recalibrate sea level don't the planes
have independent meters and gauges that
are not reliant upon control towers to
determine how far they are up in the air
plane totally explodes after crashing
because movie John McClane assesses the
damage from the comfort of a studio in
its blue screen that agent named deck
the reunion of Holly and Thornburgh is
really nothing but Holly insulting this
guy which is great I guess if you feel
like thornbird needs to be made fun of
some more but Jesus how much abuse is
William Atherton the actor have to put
up with after these movies and
Ghostbusters meanwhile despite the fact
that only one runway has been closed
this woman is either a terrible reporter
or a terrible actress
I'm not comfortable picking between the
two died no my get ready for some good
times this guy is in on it and evil my
question is how did the evil planners
know for a fact this guy's squad will be
called here I mean everything depends on
it but what if the general in charge
decides it let's send in this new SEAL
Team six and see what they're made of in
Colonel Stewart one of your men
no not anymore it's not yeah but it's a
conflict of interest I mean they just
give
better or worse Trudeau doesn't answer
but the movies editing does what about
the air phone idea there's 18 planes up
there only five and have those phones we
got through this really and can't those
three planes now communicate to the
other planes through their radios hell I
know they can because later the pilots
of Holly's plane say this attention all
air traffic on this frequency in Dulles
area so who says that radio signal has
to just beep right we switch the
frequency from the tower over the one in
the beacon we pump up the wattage and we
can talk to our place and those bastards
who did this will never know and that
was the maple street acting troupe doing
their favorite scene from die hard - why
is this military guy giving intel to
McClane after McLean's already been
banned from the investigation are they
old army buddies this is the only
channel available to us bad guys who
thought of everything somehow didn't
plan for this outer marker beacon both
thankfully Thornburg's AV guy actually
kept listening to the outer beacon for
hours in order to discover this message
on runway one-five repeat 1/5 this is
contrary to our instructions we are to
lend a drug away 1 0 if you have control
over the entire airport then why bother
changing the runway and potentially
tipping off the pilots that something
isn't right this aircraft carrying an
international terrorist doesn't have any
questions for Dulles tower about the
does another aircraft on its radar are
currently circling the airport
neither of these pilots is in on the
plan - bronzer has to take out a guard
to get to this point - what would have
happened if he wasn't guarded by someone
stupid I guess the bad guys could
overpower three people once they land
but it seems kind of like Esperanza
absolutely needed to get free for this
plan to work in fact seeing this
sequence of events it almost seems like
this plan would have gone better if he
hadn't freed himself it should be so
much fun to play don't worry about it
it's not your problem okay so why didn't
you just go ahead and do this then if
you can fly the plane these assholes
were able to sneak a radio onto this
plane which is coming from an entirely
different country and they were able to
make sure grants platoon were the first
responders when Dulles called the army
for help but apparently didn't have the
power to get their own pilots on this
thing in the first place
I've lost copy brush because I shot the
pilot and co-pilot and in doing so shot
out the window
it takes entirely too long for this
plane to crush jump fact I think this is
where fast six got its runway length
ideas bad guys just start spraying
machine gun fire well before the
recently landed general is out of the
doorway also McClane is standing in the
doorway of the airplane basically making
himself the easiest target but none of
these guys with machine guns can hit it
don't believe this man so penny two
months that's all to orchestrate a
complete takeover of Dulles and have
almost everything fall your way the
plane somehow survives this barrage
bullets then they decide to throw
grenades into the cockpit which gets
McClane some idea that he needs to get
the out of there they could have simply
left them right outside the cockpit door
and it would have accomplished
everything but everyone is dumb these
grenades take so long to blow McClane is
able to stupidly look at them for a long
time get the idea to eject to strap
himself in and a jack before they blow
up these guys are running out of gas but
are now getting messages from Barnes in
the tower who is using the beacon and
it's impossible for the bad guys to
crash planes anymore so why can't they
somehow get these guys to land already
is it really just runway lights at this
point yet they line up a whole bunch of
emergency vehicles on the runway and is
it possible Stewart forgot to turn off
the why's he turned on for Esperanza a
cabin attendants are turning on local
Washington broadcasting the sound is on
channel 2 B look I know Dulles isn't
telling anyone anything but considering
that a terrorist drug lord is being sent
to Dulles and there have been several
major explosions on the runways and
there's a massive amount of press here
how is there no news about Dulles on the
TV right now I mean no one saw that or
heard it to mention you better come take
a look at this cliche also this guy
figured out where the terrorists are but
because of this bureaucracy of an
airport he only feels comfortable
sharing it with McClane who is basically
the Antichrist around here this is our
last possibility which means it'll be
the one basic movie math tells me so
could be a century and it could just be
out for a walk and why is he going over
his own footsteps you can tell that from
here
most inopportune phone call ever
the leo in the departed would beg to
differ called red sitrep
we've got positive ID on Stuart's
location dumbass Lorenzo doesn't ask how
grant heard that this was Stuart's
location when he couldn't possibly have
heard anything on this phone call also
this plan requires that someone figure
out that they're in that church if it's
not for Barnes and McClain there's no
way this part of the plan happens unless
Grant somehow was plenty to say hmm I've
just got an amazing hunch where the bad
guys are to church another problem Cunha
no problem general doesn't Esperanza
know the plan doesn't he know the army
guys out there are on his team this
random truck is driving around in the
middle of nowhere it came out of nowhere
and I'm pretty sure it's the truck where
the screenplay was written Colonel
you're quite capable of confronted
yourself grant still feels the need to
prove he's a good guy - anyone listening
to this broadcast for some reason this
recorder will play audio over an air
phone and it will have broadcast quality
when it's played on the news ranch boys
are gonna kill that son of a bitch and
get it from them gonna do it they're
gonna go on a save goddamn play whatever
clean once again tries to make it sound
like everyone knows the information he
has and starts making wild accusations
without presenting the evidence
I'm adding ten cents for this because it
may be the most reckless stupid thing
I've ever seen in a movie MacLean thinks
that all the cops here will instantly
recognize that he's shooting blanks and
won't gun him down immediately for doing
this simple English could have solve
this problem McClane goes with the ultra
dumb solution by the way it feels like
this is exactly the reason why a news
outfit wouldn't just broadcast
Thornburg's message at the drop of a hat
without figuring out the situation first
Lorenzo was able to drive this car
immediately out of his parking spot
despite the fact that there are
thousands of assholes escaping the
airport right now
hey Calvin I'm sorry there's just simply
no way your voice would carry over this
mob scene premature celebration also
this is very interesting
even though about seven of their guys
died they filled every one of these
seats in this getaway plane pretty
goddamn unbelievable you doing out on
the wing at his place John would be
excellent at cinemasins
you just get us in the air general
you're the only man who can do it but
why you got 20 people on this mission
and nobody who could fly just in case
McClane and Grant fight on top of a wing
of a moving airplane and I'm just
sitting here pondering what a dick
physics is in almost every situation
except this one nothing on this plane
tells the kind of fuel dump was released
or that he's losing massive amounts of
you you'd be Calle Mother that does not
help gas trails and firework landing
light just in time I guess looking plain
Holly was on decided to emergently land
like ten minutes ago right look okay I
see luckily this plane was headed
straight for this very runway no flight
expert but three planes on landing on
the same runway right after another one
just landed and another one on fire
seems like a bad idea to me Holly's John
McClane's Adrian and apparently
necessary because he did this in the
first movie why does this keep happening
to us oh come on it's only been two
Christmases in a row that's a small
sample size you get this parking ticket
in front of my airport yeah yeah what
the hell sure you tore up the ticket but
the car was towed somewhere and that's
the worst part of it right
yes it's true this man has no dick good
luck
I just want to tell you both good luck
we're all counting on
I'm gonna kick your fuckin ass no more
table don't tase me bro don't you could
eat butter man wake up there's black
there's the cave oh there's the case you
take that one we'll take this one Jim
never has a second cup of coffee at home
this business will get out of control
and will get out of control and we'll be
lucky to live through that next time you
get frightened games put it our melon
strat Oh Gail April 23rd 57 kickoff in a
jet turbine no kicks